"Encuentra la suma de -15 + (-46) + (-29)". Para
encontrar el resultado, primero visualicemos cómo
se representan estos números, así que dibujaremos
una recta numérica para cada uno de ellos:
-15 se va a ver algo así, tenemos por aquí al 0
y digamos que este es -15. Si queremos podemos
representar a -15 como una flecha que apunta
desde el 0 hasta -15, la longitud de la flecha
es el valor absoluto de -15, es la distancia
desde 0 y entonces tiene una longitud de 15,
mientras que la flecha señalando a la izquierda
nos indica que es negativo, pero el valor
absoluto de 15 es la longitud de la flecha. Bien,
hagamos lo mismo para -46. Una vez más dibujemos
una recta numérica: el 0 se encuentra por acá,
mientras que -46 estará por acá, -46. Observa:
es la misma idea, la distancia entre -46 y 0,
o podemos verlo como el valor absoluto de -46,
es 46, y su dirección es a la izquierda, por eso
llegamos al número -46. El signo en este caso,
el signo negativo realmente nos dice si
estamos a la izquierda o a la derecha del 0,
el valor absoluto nos dice qué tan lejos estamos
a la izquierda o a la derecha del 0. Finalmente
hagamos lo mismo para -29, lo mismo para -29:
una vez más dibujemos una recta numérica,
aquí tenemos el 0 y -29 estará aproximadamente
por aquí. Estamos estimando. Una vez más -29
está exactamente a 29 unidades del 0, entonces
esta longitud es 29, y apunta a la izquierda,
por eso es -29. Si tuviéramos 29 estaríamos
a 29 unidades a la derecha del 0. Bien,
ya representamos todos estos números y podemos ver
cómo lucen sus valores absolutos. Ahora pensemos
qué pasa si los sumamos. Una forma de pensar
acerca de la suma de estos números es sumar estas
flechas, es decir, si ponemos esta flecha verde
donde termina esta flecha magenta a su izquierda,
y después de la flecha verde colocamos de la misma
manera la flecha anaranjada. Vamos a hacer lo:
primero dibujamos una recta numérica más grande
porque ahora tendremos una flecha más grande,
empezamos en 0 y primero tenemos -15, nos
moveremos 15 unidades a la izquierda para
llegar a -15, después nos moveremos 46 unidades
otra vez a la izquierda para obtener -15 + -46,
así que vamos a colocarla, nos moveremos 46
unidades más a la izquierda, y en un momento
sabremos a qué número llegamos, aproximadamente
será así de largo. Simplemente estamos colocando
esta flecha verde empezando donde termina
la flecha magenta que representa al -15,
colocamos la flecha verde después de ella y ahora
todavía no sabemos a qué el número hemos llegado,
tenemos que hacer un pequeño cálculo por aquí, y
de hecho ese es el punto de este problema. Pero lo
que sí conocemos es la longitud de esta flecha
verde, su longitud es 46, es 46 unidades a la
izquierda. También vamos a escribir la longitud
de la flecha magenta que sabemos que es 15. Por
último tenemos esta flecha anaranjada que sabemos
que tiene una longitud de 29, 29 unidades a la
izquierda, podemos verla así, tiene una longitud
de 29. Y ahora sí, una vez hecho todo esto,
¿dónde estamos?, ¿a dónde llegamos en nuestra
recta numérica? Bueno, la longitud total que
tenemos a la izquierda será 15 + 46 + 29, pero
ojo, apunta a la izquierda, así que tendremos
un número negativo. Entonces podemos ver que como
todos estos tienen el mismo signo, entonces esto
es lo mismo que el valor absoluto de -15 que
es 15 más el valor absoluto de -46 que es 46,
más el valor absoluto de -29 que es 29, y después
tomamos el negativo de este resultado. Así que
vamos a sumarlos: 15 + 46 + 29 es igual a, veamos:
5 + 6 es 11, 11 + 9 es 20, llevamos 2, 2 +1 es 3,
3 + 4 es 7, 7 + 2 es 9, así que llegamos a 90,
la longitud total es de 90 unidades. Si sumamos
las flechas obtenemos una longitud de 90 unidades,
pero cuidado, no es 90 a la derecha, si tuviéramos
90 a la derecha todos estos números deberían de
ser positivos y tendríamos como resultado más 90,
pero aquí tenemos 90 a la izquierda, así que
cuando sumas todos estos no llegamos a más 90,
llegaremos a -90. Una forma de pensar en esto es
que como todos estos números tienen el mismo signo
entonces el resultado será igual al negativo de
la suma del valor absoluto de -15 más el valor
absoluto de -46 más el valor absoluto de -29. Y
esto se ve muy elegante, pero sólo es una suma de
la longitud de la flecha magenta que representa
el valor absoluto de -15 más la longitud de la
flecha verde que representa el valor absoluto
de -46 más la longitud de la flecha naranjada,
que representa el valor absoluto de -29.
Por lo tanto, 15 + 46 + 29 suman 90,
pero como apuntan a la izquierda, entonces le
pondremos el signo negativo, así obtenemos -90.